[Musique]
il est un peu plus de secondes de mieux
à passer l'examen du bac 2 en 2018 un
peu plus de 3000 en russie en 2010 n 10
était un peu plus de 65000 en 2016
il était un peu plus de 73 pendant les
trois années qui ont qui nous ont
précédés le nombre d'élèves et accèder à
l'examen du bac 2 à 10 minutes
donc c'est à dire que les portes de
sortie entre le pc et le bac se sont
multipliés pour ces élèves là les portes
qui pourrait soit des grossesses souvent
à désirer soit l'abandon scolaire pour
un millier de raison je vous assure vous
en serez surpris
soit pour une obligation de productivité
précoce un âge tendre il est obligé de
prendre en charge tout ou partie de sa
famille madame monsieur bonsoir je suis
comme ivy bean et nous allons parler de
notre système éducatif
quand on parle de système éducatif il
faut comprendre que d'abord c'est
l'ensemble des tâches que les différents
acteurs du système doivent accomplie
pour le bien des appelants puisque le
système éducatif c'est d'abord et avant
tout tous les apprenants donc les
enseignants doivent transmettre ce
savoir
les parents doivent veiller au bien-être
des abdos le monde religieux
traditionnel doit être le gardien de la
morale et de l'éthique
selon
yves est aujourd'hui c'est d'inviter le
monde numérique avec tout son lot
d'informations et de déviations en
espérant que cela puisse être régulée
donc un système éducatif c'est d'avoir
tout ça et le système éducatif actuel
tel que nous le connaissons est
confrontée à des défis à de gros défis
quand on parle de fracture numérique
nos amis qui sont passés ne dit pas le
contraire quand on parle de
l'inadéquation formation emploi
c'est je pense que ça vous parle quand
on parle de manque d'autorité parentale
voilà la liste est longue de ces
défis-là auquel poule au moment le
système éducatif que nous connaissons
n'arrivent pas à trouver de solution
durable
c'est toujours à tâtons et c'est à ton
là va prendre un peu de temps de temps
qui risque de durer longtemps
on ne peut pas leur en vouloir au mois
ils ont la volonté de le faire
en attendant pourquoi ne pas essayer le
système alternatif
quand je parle de système alternatif
disant nous disons nous bien une vérité
je ne parle pas d'un système kiva venez
prendre la place de l'ancien système ça
en est d'accord je ne parle pas d'un
système qui va venir payer un choc non
il n'est pas question ici un système qui
va permettre justement de profiter des
avantages de l'ancien système et de
colmater les brèches de l'ancien système
du coup il y aura possibilité de
mobilité
deux systèmes mais ce sera une
alternative offerte aux acteurs de
l'éducation
tout ça pour le bien des apprenants
alors pourquoi est ce que je propose un
système alternatif d'avoir autour
comprendre une chose le système actuel
tel qu'il est est basé sur certaines
pratiques qui aujourd'hui ne nous et non
plus je ne prétends pas fait la liste
complète de tous ceux qui est entre
guillaume est mauvais mais je vais en
citer quelques-uns
histoire de nous faire voir un peu là le
bien fondé de ce donjon balle quand je
prends les rien l'idée qu'on enseigne à
l'école tout à l'heure ce sont les
bienvenus et nous a fait une belle
démonstration avec son petit bidule
en quoi est ce que la réflexion la
conception les essais est
l'aboutissement pouvoir voir son robot
l' envoi est ce que les trous et les
toute l'histoire de majorer de
christophe colomb laet et à faire ça
nous avons besoin d'un système
alternatif notre système est basé sur
une mémorisation obligé vous devez
apprendre et venir donner ce que vous
avez appris mot pour vous l'êtes hall
1,1 au véhicule pour espérer avoir une
bonne note
la borne haute vous permet d'avoir un
bon diplôme le bon diplôme soit disant
est la garantie d'un bon métier un bon
travail
et lorsque vous retrouver dans le
travail j'ai perdu vous savez pas trop
opaque on cause qu'est ce qu'on fait
c'est pas parce que vous devenez un
alien dans un monde qui va vite dans un
monde qui est devenu tactile ou au fait
pour être ce que vous nous faites pas on
n'est pas parce que vous avez fait vous
avez mémorisées vous êtes devenu quoi
c'est devenu un automate et sanogo qui
va vite pour la besoins des gens crient
notre système est basé sur des notions
théoriques faux lumineuse où vous avez
aujourd'hui des ingénieurs agronomes qui
peuvent s'asseoir à son bureau en
costume cravate et ne sont jamais allés
sur le terrain à ce qu'ils ont appris
tout ça dans les lignes qui ne sont
jamais qui n'ont jamais osé fait de la
pratique les ingénieurs soi-disant des
informaticiens qui ne savent pas à quoi
ressemble un tablet ou carrément un
écran tactile
ils savent pas ce que c'est nous avons
besoin d'un système alternatif
vous connaissez de ses diplômés de ces
personnes soit disant compétentes mais
qui une fois embauchés sont assises et
attendent que vous le dise que vous l'a
dit exactement ce qu'il doit faire
parfois ils doivent penser ce qu'ils
doivent penser le patron ne m'a pas dit
de fait ça je ne fais pas bien haut ses
5,5 c'est comme ça qu'on a tout fait il
faut pas fuir par embrouiller ici
ce profil dessous ce profit de béni oui
oui et justement à l'image de notre
système actuel c'est simple que ça vaut
lui et sa brawn a plus besoin
on a besoin d'un système alternatif du
suspens donc l'alternative que je
propose devrait être basée sur
l'orientation
mais attention l'augmentation de j pal
ce n'est pas l'orientation tel qu on le
faisait il ya quelques années tu fais
bien le français l'anglais les séries
attendues fin de licence musicale
ces lycées où l'idée ce n'est pas de ça
qu'il s'agit
geo du l'orientation que nous faisons
c'est beaucoup plus bon quelle est ta
passion qu'est ce qui te fait vibrer ok
tu le fais aller au bon niveau le fait
ça c'est ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui
mais pour moi c'est encore pas assez là
où je voudrais qu'on tende c'est de se
poser la question comment faire ce que
je fais pour développer ma communauté ou
d'une europe et mon pays pour participer
à l'avancement du milieu dans lequel je
suis est donc ce système poupe pour ça
ce système donc sera basée
essentiellement sur les réalités locales
l'enseignement ne va plus rien su des
exemples de dragon mais l'enseignement
va se baser sur le cas pratique de la
vendeuse de tableau pour ceux qui
connaissent qui dans le quartier a
commencé par vendre depuis que j'ai 5
ans et qui continue de vendre jusqu'à ce
que je sois mariée et que j'ai déménagé
de la mesure de mes parents je vis à 25
km mais je reviens toujours pas acheté
chez elle parce qu'il ya toujours
fluence parce que le hâbleur joola et
elle fait ça son business blond sans
stratégie de communication sans plan
deux autres comptables érigé toujours
comme ça ça ce n est qu en pratique que
nous devrions étudier à l'école mon
entrée à notre appel
comment réussir chez nous par mots pour
nous ce système pourrait être faits
pourraient être réalisées non plus pas
des enseignants qui sont là parce qu'il
faut fait des heures pour gagner des
sous donc ils vendent le plus de ça fait
plus de ces fantoches et donkey coudrier
les goûts les d'aider les répétitions
etc
on a dépassé ça ce système ne pourrait
être réalisé que par des enseignants qui
sont d'abord et avant tout des coachs
l'enseignant doit prendre en charge un
groupe dab renom et les remue les deux
points à un web et le moins a aidé à un
niveau 1 et le point p et dans un niveau
8 sur une échelle de 10 10 étant le
meilleur est bon ce fait cela pas pour
se faire oublier
en faisant cela l'expérience accrue des
abonnés passent pas la pratique parce
que l'avenant il comprend notamment
parce que on lui a expliqué une théorie
à laquelle inapi j'ai kiffé ce 20% du
vocabulaire est encore voie mais il
comprend ce qu'il a fait il le comprend
à sa manière il le comprend parce que il
a une connexion avec ce qu'il veut et ça
ça change
ce système sera aussi basé sur un
service militaire obligatoire
ben je vois beaucoup commençaient paris
vous êtes d'accord avec moi que quand on
ne prend que notre vieux de l'eau mais
l'indiscipliné devient la chose la mieux
partagée
donc ça c'est 100 commandés et ce
système devra aussi est basé sur une
sélection rigoureuse des hubs libéré et
audiovisuelle écoutez je me suis amusé à
faire il ya quelques temps eu déni comme
qu'on commence à pleurer sans semant un
recensement des chaînes de radio et télé
donc si ma radio je devrais pas
l'habitude c'était sur le téléphone j'ai
dénombré les chiens de stations fm j'ai
retrouvé 23 et pour la dea
j'en ai compté 11 ça c'est de mon point
de vue ça langage courant sur cette
population là en les écoutant en posant
des questions rendre questionnant les
gens à gauche à prague
j'ai trouvé au moins une douzaine je dis
bien moins d'une douzaine initiaux
éducative vous imaginez tous à l'ensae
mais à longueur de journée et ça parle
d'autre chose que les collègues avec ça
on se plaint que le niveau baisse avec
ce plat que les enfants ne parlent pas
français
et last but not least ce qu' il faudrait
une prise de conscience du jeune abou
qu'ils comprennent que à chaque moment à
chatons il a du temps à perdre ou du
temps à gagner à lui de faire rejoindre
et donc chaque heure chaque minute
chaque jour qui passe peut être utilisé
à bon escient pour faire quelque chose
pour aider d'abord lui même et au sénat
lui même il est son entourage et en
aidant son entourage il est sa
communauté
le continent africain à partir du moment
où le jeu en prenant conscience de son
rôle en tant que juste un maillon dans
cette chaîne là sachant que plus il est
faux plus la chaîne est forte
je sais pas pourquoi on va aller accuser
qui que ce soit mais c'est un système
éducatif qui va produit une citoyenne
font les jeunes citoyens qui vont
permettre à l'afrique de devenir autre
chose d'eux mêmes mais pour le fait de
quoi avons nous besoin
je n'ai déjà dit les enseignants qui
sont des coachs ou bien des manteaux
mais aussi ce que j'appelle une
université par un doublé malgré ce
système éducatif
c'est l'ensemble des tâches des
différents acteurs de l'éducation et
donc les pins aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
parents qui voient là le rôle de parent
logorrhée mais qui ne le font pas assez
bien et quand on le dit certes elle a
relaxé d'autre de l'axé pas vraiment il
faudrait maintenant les réformes et les
sensibiliser le leur expliquer le
montrer que le rôle de parent le site ne
se limite pas juste a donné l'argent de
poche et à donner des fessées mais va
bien au delà de cela il faudrait aussi
un réseau de partenaires professionnels
parce que j'ai parlé des modèles et des
références qui seront cités en exemple
il faut certaines personnes qui ont
l'afrique dans lequel c'est eux qui vont
venir partager les expériences avec ces
jeunes là pou fé de ces jeunes
d'aujourd'hui
les adultes eux mais qui vont bien
au-delà des limites que nous nous avons
eu bien sûr les ressources pédagogiques
utiles mais locale
quand je ne protège la vidéo de nos
interventions dit si cela peut très bien
une canicule ou bien comme un suppôt du
cou à certains votants dans certaines
filières dans certains s'y colle il y en
a beaucoup et il y en a qui les rend
compte de ce genre sont légion et
surtout on aura besoin de beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de bonne volonté au
conclure disons la vérité quand je parle
d'un système éducatif alternatif
africaine le système éducatif tel qu'il
est aujourd'hui chez nous est calquée
sur le modèle occidental
mais le système éducatif occidentale
aujourd'hui a montré ses limites au bo
il existe de plus en plus de systèmes
alternatifs occidentaux et il ya
certains pays qui ont carrément refusé
le système éducatif occidental tel que
nous le connaissons qui ne pratique le
système éducatif alternatifs chez eux et
qu'ils s'en sortent bien
quand je ne donne que le comme la
finlande avec le système de modeuses
rondes et olli rehn
steiner et tout le reste avec des
résultats
boire ou alors c'est en question nous
attendons qu'est ce que nous entendons
on n'a plus le choix on peut le faire on
doit le faire et moi je pense qu'on va
le faire parce qu'on a compris nous
avons tout ce qu'il faut pour le faire
pour réussir
alors allons-y réussissons je suis
lyonnais merci
[Musique]